[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoind dans
fileco l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
pardon une entreprise arsisienne a été
sélectionné par le programme pmup un
programme d'aide au développement de la
région Île-de-France et nous dit
ouvrirons que d'autres chefs
d'entreprise sont à l'honneur cette
semaine avec les prix de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin les Smart
des 3 jours consacrés aux entreprise
spécialisé dans les objets connectés
l'événement de la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des Yvelines nous a donné
l'envie de découvrir les sociétés
ivelinois qui travaillent dans ce
domaine et puis nous retrouverons
Camille luret bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
membre de l'association Le bonheur est
dans le prê une toute jeune structure
qui permet notamment de promouvoir des
projets agricoles via des press
solidaire tout à fait on en découvre
plus dans un instant mais avant cela
place aux informations économiques de la
semaine hier la CGPME organisé les la
remise du prix des Trophées des clubs
d'entrepreneuriat au féminin au départ
150 candidatures pour H prix dans huit
catégories les chefs d'entreprisees
ivelinoises ont aussi tiré leur épingle
du jeu auil fin de la société coup
d'éclat une agence de conseil en
communication loge en Josas a remporté
le trophée coup de cœur Caroline
lebuvant de son côté créatrice d'une
marque de lingerie Bibi et Bibi destiné
aux femmes atteintes d'un cancer du sein
remporte elle le trophée de
l'encouragement sa société est basée à
Saint-Rémi les Chevreuse et les prix ont
été remis par la ministre du droit des
femmes aider les entreprises innovantes
d'ide-de-fance dans leur développement
c'est l'objectif du programme pmup via
des aides financières et un
accompagnement cette année une
entreprise yvelinoise et le rat expem
découverte de cette société de bois
d'Arc des images de Juliette pousson ici
on est dans le laboratoire en fait sur
lequel on va mener des tests
d'élaborations de débugs ce genre de
choses donc là on est en train de de
faire des test sur une une de nos cartes
de nos développements pour un grand un
grand groupe
industrielenvironnement cette société
arcisienne est spécialisée dans
l'embarqué ce circuit imprimé sera
intégré dans cette boîte noire il devra
supporter les chocs et vibrations d'un
hélicoptè terre le groupe expem et ses
trois filiales travaillent aujourd'hui
avec de grands groupes internationaux en
quelques années son chiffre d'affaires a
dépassé les 3 millions d'euros pour un
effectif de 15 personnes et il ne compte
pas s'arrêter là alors pour aider à
mener à terme son développement expem a
postulé au dispositif pmup un concours
remporté avec succès ce dispositif de la
région île-de-fance propose des aides
financière pouvant aller jusqu'à 250000
€ et un accompagnement un quart des
candidats passeront la sélection le
projet doit donc être ambitieux et
innovant sur 2014 nous nous avons mis en
place un axe euh que je vais qualifierer
de
d'infrastructure puisque nous allons
lancer une démarche de certification ISO
9001 et ISO 14000 sur lequel le
programme nous accompagne nous avons
aussi un deuxième axe qui est un axe RSE
donc responsabilité sociale de
l'entreprise et là le programme nous
accompagne aussi à mettre en place des
indicateurs et à vérifier que l'on
progresse sur indicateurs et le
troisième axe que j'ai évoqué c'est un
développement international 2015-2016
sur l'activité aujourd'hui logicielle de
tout ce qui est Linux embarké le but
exporter son expertise et ses produits
le dispositif pmup est ouvert au PME
franilienne de 5 salariés au plus ayant
au moins 3 ans d'existence depuis sa
création en 2008 il a accompagné 780 PME
et octroyé 82 millions d'euros de
subvention depuis maintenant 115 ans les
Conseillers du Commerce extérieur de la
France cherche à développer la balance
commerciale de l'Hexagone parmi leurs
actions conseiller les pouvoirs publics
parrainés des société française à
l'étranger mais aussi former les jeunes
à l'international pour cela il
récompense entre autres des étudiants
pour leur parcours scolaire à l'étranger
c'était le cas mardi à Versailles ces
lycéens ont effectué des stages de 2 à 7
mois en Europe à Dubaï aux États-Unis
ils se sont démarqués par la qualité de
leur rapport de stage et ont reçu des
chèqus de 300 à 500 €. ils tenteront
leur chance maintenant au concours
nationale pour information ces
conseillers bénévoles ont exercé un
poste de responsabilité à
l'international ils sont nommés pour un
mandat de 3 ans par décret du Premier
ministre 50 bénévoles font partie du
comité
ivelinois la Chambre de commerce de et
d'industrie des ivelin lance son 10e
programme plateau plateau est un réseau
qui rassemble des entrepreneurs de PME
et des cadres de grandes entreprises sur
un territoire donné une forme de
parrainage ce soir le réseau Paris
pardon le réseau plateau Paris saacé
sera officiellement lancé 75 PME issus
de l'industrie et du service aux
entreprises seront accompagnés par 12
grandses entreprises un partenariat a
été mis en place avec la CCI de lesson
qui englobe également une partie du
périmètre de l'oïen l'opération
d'intérêt national Paris à clé le but
permettre des échanges et une montée en
compétence des dirigeants de PME mode
Paris David animatrice du plateau nous
en dévoile un peu plus les groupes de
travail aborderont diverses thématiques
qui seront choisis au fur à mesure du du
programme ce ne sont pas des groupes
thématiques on va l'objectif quand on
constitue les groupe c'est de mélanger
dans chaque groupe les secteurs
d'activités et les profils des
dirigeants pour qu' a une richesse des
échanges et pendant 2 ans les
participants se réuniront une fois par
mois quatre groupes plateau Paris
saintclay sera lancé jeudi il sera
constitué de 75 dirigeants de PME dont
le profil ce sont des entreprises en
fort développement à caractère
d'innovation pour la
plupart et qui seront accompagnés par 12
grandes entreprise du territoire du de
Paris saclé donc le but finalement c'est
c'est une sorte de parrainage oui le
l'objectif de plateau la méthode plateau
c'est l'accompagnement des dirigeants de
PME par des cadres de grandes
entreprises et qu'est-ce que ça leur
permet le les apports de plateau il y en
a ils sont multiples mais les les
principaux sont rompre l'isolement du
dirigeant
d'entreprise bénéficier de
l'accompagnement des cadres de grandes
entreprises mais aussi échanger entre
dirigeants de PME pour trouver des
solutions à des problématiques communes
et le réseau plateau lancé en 2001 dans
des département a réuni près de 880 PME
et 153 grandes entreprises du
département du 20 au 22 juin le Maker
faire rassemblera au 104 des créateurs
qui fabriquent sous toutes les formes
robotique cuisine couture les petites
imprimantes 3D en plein développement
depuis quelques années devraient être à
l'honneur la société a qu Technologies
spécialiste du matériel pédagogique
technologique c'est d'ailleurs peu à peu
tourné vers ce secteur d'activité pour
les établissements scolaires mais aussi
les particuliers elle sera présente à ce
salon nous avons rencontré ce dirigeant
aux Ulis bah c'est pour montrer
finalement notre savoir-faire de de
Maker parce que finalement on est des
fabrican et autour de l'impriment 3D il
y a tout ce mouvement des makers qui se
qui se développe le faire c'est un jeu
de mot he entre Maker et puis faire F et
donc pour nous c'est important d'y être
parce que d'abord on est des fabricants
et puis on est dans cette mouvance des
imprimants 3D qui pour nous constiueent
vraiment aujourd'hui un second métier
puis qu'on a une bonne partie des
imprimants 3D pratiquement 40 % des
imprimant 3D qu'on distribue qui sont
distribués en dehors du circuit
éducation et nous aurons l'occasion de
développer ce sujet lors d'un dossier
plus complet sur l'impression 3D la
réforme des rythmes scolaires bouleverse
l'organisation des communes une mais va
favoriser le recrutement dans le secteur
de l'animation à Montini par exemple un
forum été organisé samedi dernier
objectif trouver 28 animateurs pour la
rentrée prochaine les postes sont
variables temps complet ou partiel mais
les postulants doivent être diplômés du
BAFA ou encore être en formation pour la
responsable de la vie scolaire les
postes ne sont pas si faciles à pourvoir
il est difficile de recruter oui parce
qu'on a besoin d'un grand nombre
d'animateurs sur la ville c'est souvent
effectivement une voie que les jeunes
prennent parce qu'ils sont ils arrêtent
à un moment donné leur cursus scolaire
et espèrent effectivement avec une
expérience de babyitting ou autre
pouvoir effectivement intégrer ce cursus
alors que c'est une réellement une voix
qui va devenir qui va se
professionnaliser qu' commence et qui je
pense avec la réforme des rythmes
scolaires va permettre effectivement de
valoriser cette cette
[Musique]
voie et pour cette page d'entretien nous
recevons aujourd'hui camilleoré bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes donc responsable de
communication au sein de l'association
le bonheur et dans le prê cette
association s'est créée il y a un mois
maintenant oui la l'AG constitutive
c'était en mars 2014 et les statutes ont
été déposé en avril donc on est vraiment
une toute jeune association sur le
territoire alors vous délivrez des prêt
solidaires à des agriculteurs des
environs la première cagnotte solidaire
comme vous l'appelez a été remis à un
marécher Damien Leroi nous l'avons
rencontré lors de sa dernière livraison
à manilé am avant de commencer donc cet
entretien je vous propose d'écouter son
témoignage depuis 5 ans Damien Leroi
fournit des légumes pour la map de manie
dans cette Association pour le Maintien
d'une Agriculture paysane le marécher et
ses clients évitent tout intermédiaire
un atout économique mais aussi
écologique car l'idée est de privilégier
les circuits courts cette semaine dans
les paniers des courgettes radis salad
pommes de terre et concombre Damien a
transformé son exploitation céréalière
pour se spécialiser dans le maréchage
biologique mais depuis 2 ans les
difficultés financières se sont
accumulées principalement à cause des
conditions
climatiques biologique ça a été vraiment
une deux années très dures à cause de ce
printemps difficile
et bon ça fait maintenant 6 ans que j'ai
démarréin mais ça reste très court pour
vraiment assoir une activité solide et
de années de suite ça m'a amené à à
avoir des problèmes de trésor très
important récolte amoindr ramassage plus
difficile alors il y a 3 mois il a
exposé son problème à ses clients dit
voilà j'ai un souci c'est que j'y arrive
plus quoi financièrement je rame je rame
bon je fais tout ce que je peux mais
c'est dur et puis ben les uns et les
autres ont dit mais on va pas te laisser
comme ça on doit pouvoir t'aider les
différents membres de la map se sont
constitués en association le bonheur est
dans le prê les volontaires ont alimenté
une cagnotte solidaire bilan 1000 €
prêté à l'agriculteur et remboursable
sur 3 ans de quoi éponger les dettes
c'est très important de voir que la
solidariité marche bien au-delà du lien
social c'est vraiment ça réchauffe les
cœurs comme on dit le montant de la
cagnote a vite été dépassé devant
l'afflux des prêteurs Damien le roi
devrait bénéficier d'un deuxème prêt de
2500 € pour acheter du matériel comme un
semoir de quoi augmenter sa productivité
déjà d'autres agriculteurs du territoire
sont venus pousser la porte de cette
association de nouveaux projets agricole
devrait voir le jour grâce au
présolidaire alors on va rentrer un peu
plus dans les détails donc Damien Leroi
livre qure AMAP don celle de manier que
l'on vient de voir mais aussi une ague
en cours dont vous faites partie
personnellement donc quand cet
agriculteur vous a parlé de de ces
problème de trésorerie les quatre ambles
se sont réunis finalement on doné un
conseil tout à fait en fait on allait
pas laisser tomber Damien et
effectivement
l'agriculture l'agriculture ben ça
nécessite du beau temps ça nécessite des
conditions favorables et là on a subi
deux années qui ont été vraiment
difficiles alors évidemment une AMAP
c'est déjà un soutien puisqu'on
préfinance la production et des fois bah
quand le soleil n'est pas là les paniers
sont plus petits donc c'est déjà un
premier pas mais là il fallait vraiment
faire autre chose et on s'est tourné en
fait toutes les associations enfin
toutes les toutes les AMAP parce que
toute seule enfin on pouvait rien faire
on s'est mis ensemble on est allé voir
AMAP î de France MIRAMAP qui est le
mouvement régional des AMAP pour voir
ben qu'est-ce qu'il est possible de
faire et on a a décidé de créer une
association pour pour essayer d'apporter
un financement via un prêt à taux zéro
alors vous avez créé cette association
le but donc c'est de créer des cagnottes
solidaires quand il y en a des besoins
finalement les objectifs sont aussi plus
généraux oui tout à fait on est on est
là aussi pour favoriser le lien social
maintenir l'agriculture de proximité on
sait que c'est très dur aujourd'hui pour
les agriculteurs à la fois de
s'installer et aussi de se maintenir sur
le territoire on sait très bien qu'il y
a qu'il y a des grosses demandes dans en
logement qui a des grosses demandes en
transport et du coup peu à peu les les
terrains agricoles sont grignotés donc
Damien il a une ferme dans leur aoire
donc c'est déjà un petit peu loin de de
nous mais on essae au maximum de
favoriser les circuits courts et directs
alors vous avez pour le moment 80
adhérents dans l'association donc pour
l'inst 84 adhérents 84 adhérents et 80
qui ont donné pour les 10000 € mais ce
chiffre doit être encore revu puisqu'on
continue de recevoir des des prêts alors
justement les ces prêts comment
finalement vous choisissez les projets
que vous allez aider alors ben déjà on
les choisit parce que en tant qu'amap on
a plusieurs producteurs qui connaissent
plus ou moins des des difficultés donc
là Damien c'est c'est lui qui est venu
nous parler de ses difficultés
financières donc ça a été un premier
projet pour de la trésorerie après nous
avons d'autres producteurs qui ont des
besoins qui sont peut-être plus modestes
parce que là le prêt est de 10000 € mais
Damen le prêt maximum d'ailleurs que
vous oui tout à fait parce qu'on n'est
pas une banque hein je le je je le dis
très clairement nous ne sommes pas une
banque on est on est on est là pour
aider un agriculteur à un moment donné
donc par exemple on a Damien a besoin
aussi d'un semoir c'est 2500 €
d'occasion donc ce sont des choses qu'on
peut aider à financer mais on ne
remplace pas une banque pour les gros
projets c'est c'est pas nous ça reste
des petits projet à zéro ce qui leur
permet également donc du coup de de
pouvoir financer sans sans argent
supplémentaire tout à fait donc là le
prêt de Damien Leroi est remboursable au
bout d'un an ce sera le cas pour il
commence en fait comme c'est un prêt qui
est important notre objectif c'est pas
d'étrangler Damien en lui demandant de
rembourser tout de suite nous on peut
attendre on fait un prêt sur 3 ans donc
il va rembourser qu'à partir de la
première année parce que dans
l'agriculture on préfinance l'achat des
semis et cetera mais la récolte elle est
plus tard donc en fait l'argent arrive
plus tard donc ça permet de lâcher un
peu de l'Est et de laisser Damien
pouvoir pouvoir respirer financièrement
et et avoir un petit peu de temps pour
nous rembourser après les conditions des
prêts vont varier en fonction des
projets par exemple on a une productrice
qui qui va avoir besoin d'ici quelques
quelques temps d'un frigo euh ce sera
pas un prê sur 3 ans là ce sera
peut-être un peu moins mais euh c'est
dans la discussion avec les agriculteurs
les producteurs et en fonction des
besoins et des projets pour décider du
coup vous réunissez le conseil
d'administration de l'association euh
qui valide ou non finalement le le
projet et ensuite vous proposez euh aux
différents adhérents qui veut prêter voà
exactement en fait euh le producteur
vient nous présenter son projet alors ça
peut être très vaste là par exemple
exemple on a des producteurs de viande
de de bœuf qui veulent un petit peu
développer leur activité et trouver
d'autres sources de revenus et ils
veulent faire des chambres d'ôutes donc
pour cela ils ont besoin de financement
pour rénover leur leur cuisine alors on
peut se dire que c'est pas vraiment de
l'agriculture mais en même temps ça leur
donne une rémunération supplémentaire
quand on voit les prix les les les
rémunérations des agriculteur mais c'est
quand même un quelque chose qui qui est
un vrai plus et qui pourrait être
financé par notre notre association et
si finalement l'objectif n'est pas
atteint le le prêt demandé n'est pas ah
bah c'est pas grave si par exemple on
fait un prêt de 2000 € et qu'on en
atteint que 1000 ben on prête 1000 € on
prête ce qu'on a on va pas on va pas
inventer l'argent qu'on n pas juste pour
pouvoir prêter de l'argent au producteur
il faut être membre de l'association
donc adhérant de l'association et donc
il faut que la personne fasse un à une
adhésion à 15 € pour 3 ans voilà qui
nous permet nous de faire de la
communication de pouvoir se déplacer on
était par exemple au Jardin des Plantes
à manie pour parler de ce projet donc il
faut obligatoirement être adhérent en
tout cas pour ceux qui seraient
intéressés c'est donc ouvert qu'on soit
la map ou non ouvert à tous tout fa
c'est ouvert à tout le monde il faut
juste être particulier parce que on ne
prend pas de personne morale parce que
c'est beaucoup trop compliqué à à gérer
voilà très bien mais je vous remercie en
tout cas d'êtreevenenu sur notre plateau
on passe tout de suite au dossier la
semaine la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des organise en juin et
juillet ces premiers Smart des des
journées consacrées aux entreprises
spécialisées dans les objets connectés
alors c'est-à-dire des objets parfois
dit intelligents qui communiquent entre
eux l'occasion pour nous de partir à la
rencontre des sociétés ivinoises qui
travaillent dans ce domaine un reportage
de yolen Torz et de la rédaction pas un
jour ne passe sur l'annonce d'une
nouveauté dans le domaine les objets
connectés intègre petit à petit notre
quotidien j'ai pas d'a priori contre par
contre à titre personnel pour le moment
j'en utilise pas mais effecement on sait
ce que c'est quand même on s'informe
j'attends que ça soit plus abordable au
niveau financier et puis je vais vivre
avec mon temps mais c'est tout je pense
que quand on l'utilise au bout d'un
moment si on est habitué on peut plus
s'en passer mais si on commence pas à
l'utiliser je pense qu'on peut vraiment
s'en passer c'est c'est une question de
génération quoi selon plusieurs études
d'ici 2020 le marché se composera de
près de 80 milliards d'objets
intelligents contre 15 milliards en 2012
d'après une enquête menée par institut
Haris interactive on note un fort
attrait pour les objets connectés au
service de la maison mais aussi pour la
voiture connectée loin derrière les
consommateurs citent les montres
connectées les bracelets ou encore les
lunettes cette automobile à première vue
banale peut-être piloté à partir de
cette tablette un projet conçu par une
société
inimontaine pour démarrer la voiture on
la on mettre le marche avant et après on
on tenant pu là l'accélération va va
commencer à augmenter et après on va
bouger la tablette pour bouger les
volants de la voiture pour que cela
fonctionne la tablette et la voiture
sont relié à un même réseau via une
connexion Wii sur la voiture c'est cette
petite antenne qui permet de la brancher
au réseau toutes les informations reçues
sont ensuite reliées sur ce tableau de
bord et c'est aussi via cet écran que
les informations sont transformées pour
être compréhensible par la voiture un
travail de plus de 6 mois réalisé par
trois collaborateurs mais pour le moment
il ne reste qu'au stade de projet et à
vocation très spécifiqu c'est de pouvoir
se donner quelques petites commodités
par exemple pour des gens qui sont
fatigués
handicapés donc se libérer des derniers
mètres dans un parking mais de toute
façon dans à très petite vitesse dans
des zones réservées protégées pas
question de faire ça sur la route cette
société éditrice de logiciel est
spécialisée dans les services
automobiles dans les Ives fait partie
des nombreuses entreprises engagées dans
l'innovation et le marché des objets
connectés verraz plusieurs secteurs qui
sont fortement touchés dans les evveline
l'automobile bien sûr mais également
tout ce qui est aéronautique parce
qu'effectivement au niveau aéronautique
on parle de plus en plus de drone par
exemple tout ce qui est drone aérien
donc là c'est aussi par excellence des
objets connectés la santé également est
fortement impactter de tout point de vue
quand on voit le les vrais miracles qui
sont faits dans le domaine cardiaque par
exemple c'est remarquable d'après une
étude d'Aris interactive la grande
majorité des sondés souhaite que les
objets connectés soient développés en
priorité pour la santé ensuite pour la
sécurité et enfin pour l'amélioration de
la vie quotidienne direction le musée
des Arts et Métiers à Paris nous
retrouvons une société yvelinoise qui a
installé son dispositif appelé le LIFI
un dispositif semblable au wifi sauf
qu'au lieu des ondes électromagnétiques
radio c'est la lumière qui établit la
communication grâce à la technologie
er jus 10 FO plus vite qu' le Wii quand
on éteint la lampe c'est zé quand on
l'allume c'est 1 et quand on le fait 1
milliard de fois par seconde on peut
aller à 1 gabit jusqu'à 10
GB de communication résultat la lumière
communique des informations grâce à un
récepteur bientôt miniaturisé et intégré
dans le smartphone autrement dit c'est
via ce récepteur pour le moment sous
forme de clé USB que la lumière transmet
les informations on a ici la
tablette ici un
récepteur et quand je vais le conduire
sous la
lumière automatiquement ça va déclencher
l'information de ce qu'on est en train
de voir avec ce dispositif la société
hivinoise a créé une télévision
connectée grâce à la lumière alors ici
et bien c'est très simple vous avez des
images de bon je sais pas mais on peut
de YouTube qui sont envoyés par la
lumière objectif est ainsi à terme de
pouvoir se connecter et recevoir des
informations peu importe l'endroit où
l'on se trouve on est au fin fond d'un
tunnel pour les gens de la RATP ouou des
chemins de fer ou la
SNCF pour communiquer au fin fond c'est
c'est c'est pas toujours facile dès
qu'il y a une source lumineuse on a un
point de communication avec avec
l'extérieur encore plus plus
impressionnant on est en train de de
s'attaquer au secteur des mines à 700 m
sous terre vous pourrez être en
communication Skype avec votre famille
sans aucun problème direction Versailles
dans cette société éditrice de logiciel
les produits sont spécialement conçus
pour les PME j'ai rencontré beaucoup
beaucoup de petites entreprises et euh
très régulièrement ce que celle-ci me
remontait c'est que soit elles était pas
du tout équipé en informatique ou en
télécom soit très très mal et se
débrouiller par elle-même c'est-à-dire
que bon se débrouiller avec un disque
dur externe une clé USB pour sauvegarder
leurs données on met un seul téléphone
dans une pièce et tout le monde se lève
quand le téléphone sonne pour aller
répondre résultat Marc propose une
plateforme centrale qui fait office de
serveur interne à l'entreprise et qui
permet de relier ordinateur télévision
ou encore téléphone ensemble cette
application a été développée pour cette
population de personnes non technique
qui vont pouvoir administrer leur
système et le faire évoluer en
téléchargeant des nouvelles applications
qu'on va mettre au fur et à mesure à
leur disposition et pour pouvoir ajouter
je dirais des des fonctionnalités des
services nouveaux dans dans l'entreprise
un objet connecté donc mais également
doté d'une intelligence artificielle car
il peut aussi s'adapter au mode de
fonctionnement de l'entreprise un
visiteur qui vient dans l'entreprise hop
on va prévenir l'administrateur donc en
lui indiquant qu' un nouvel ordinateur a
été détecté sur le réseau est-ce que
c'est un visiteur est-ce que c'est un
nouveau collaborateur et dans ce cas il
faut l'intégrer dans une routine de
sauvegarde avec les avec les autres
ordinateursentreprise d'après l'institut
Xerfi les objets connectés
représentaient 150 50 million d'euros de
dépenses high-tech des Français en 2013
en 2016 ces dépenses pourraient
atteindre 500 millions
d'euros et une date à retenir dans
l'agenda et un forum d'information sur
la vente directe à domicile le 26 juin à
hencour l'Espace Emploi organise cet
événement de 14h à 20h des membres de la
fédération de vente direct seront
présents pour accueillir
individuellement les candidats et
présenter leurs produits la vente à
domicile offre des débouchés pour des
temps complets mais aussi peut-être
surtout en tant que complément
d'activité pour les personnes
intéressées rendez-vous donc à l'hôtel
de ville et c'est la fin de ce filcho
merci de nous avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine très
bonne
[Musique]
soirée